[Music]
hmm this is look
i'm really trying to see if we can make
the whole show without getting too
political this is technically about
politics but that's not where we're
gonna watch the video okay uh quick
background just so you know uh this is
well you know what i don't need to say i
think he explains it hold on here we go
hello my name is mark mcgowan i am the
premier of western australia hello my
name
is mark mcgowan and i'm eubank premier
here in western australia
and
i'm the interpreter i gotta talk la
creel layupola what he's talking about
so you know how bbc had pidgin right
well now they have in western australia
because of the uh indigenous people the
aboriginal people they have a translator
so they're bbc [ __ ] yeah check it out
this is an important message to keep
aboriginal people safe for your message
and this message
a proper important one to keep everybody
important safe one
you can die from the corona or get
really sick
you will again
pass away
from this groaner
or you better get really sick one
okay but i understand what you're saying
no hold on can i understand i understood
everything she was saying so i feel like
the inverse would be true am i wrong
the universe would be true correct if i
can understand your made-up language
then it's not really a very distinct
language all the words in your language
are just from this language for instance
uh uh english spanish italian there's a
bunch of languages that are basically
all latin languages because it's all
based on latin with its own flavor
however
i could
pequito espanol i can pick up a little
bit of it but like
i can't understand spanish or italian or
you know it's a different language this
is just you're gonna get sick right man
yeah one
okay
she looks like a yam with a wig on
oh all right now i see it because i was
thinking yams like the food but no you
mean like an unpeeled yeah like just
actually you bought it at the grocery
store
it's time to get the corona needle to
keep people and country strong
the end
you time to get him this needle
blanga corona
to keep him but all the people
and country proper strong one
proper strong one
guys
i don't know man it feels like a waste
of money i don't know if you're paying
this woman or whatever they've been
mocking us for years man i kind of feel
like this is unnecessary right
can i just i
i'm throwing my name out in 2022. i
i want to be part of the new world order
man because i i'm
you there's no way that you guys aren't
laughing hysterically in these meetings
and i like we're not allowed to be funny
right yeah we're not allowed to be funny
in whatever cat part of the cast system
we're in now so i'm willing to sell out
i just want to be in on the meetings
because when you're setting this kind of
[ __ ] up
and then you're watching the video at
the next meetings you have to be
like howling laughing at both of these
people and the fact that they like
because this is like my same theory with
um
with de blasio when they were dressing
them up in wacky knicks
jerseys the next jerseys with the tags
hanging off and eating french fries and
[ __ ] juggling like a clown
and
there's just i want to be in on the
meetings where you're like all right
we're going to humiliate him a step
further the western premiere of
australia we're going to get an
aboriginal woman who looks like a gam uh
who looks like the the
female uh gremlin and then she's gonna
barely translate into a language that's
not even another language it's and then
you go isn't that going to be some of
the most insulting [ __ ] to both sides
yes and it's going to be hilarious she
looks like she should be reading a
rolling stone in the intro to family
matters
okay so i have a question for you let's
try something here for a year now i
think these people in power have been
like okay check it out there's no way
they're going to go for this one and
then they just do it all right as long
as i keep my job right okay so i'm going
to do something
let's let's do what they do i'm going to
do a press conference okay and i want
you to be my translator for inner city
new york people okay can you do that all
right okay right here we go
hello my name is royce lopez i'm with
the health services of new york city hey
yo dawg what's up deadass my name is
royce lopez i'm with the city
uh we will be mandating vaccines uh to
go to work if you work in the trash
industry starting january 1st if y'all
[ __ ] don't get this shot by
january 21st i mean and i'm saying
deadass dog
you ain't gonna have no work you ain't
gonna have no money you're gonna get no
[ __ ]
and your ass gonna be sitting in your
[ __ ] at your mom at your baby mom's
house
thank you and have a wonderful weekend
now get the [ __ ] out of here dawg
i like this i think like we we're really
reaching out to different communities
we're gonna really do well with this i
think
the corona needle will protect kids old
people men and women
well
do you uncrown a needle
gotta keep
mail a safe one
gotta keep them
oh god she does look like a california
raisin
oh man
all right you know what they do have a
good point we do have to do now a cuban
spanglish version
all right where it's a cuban guy mixing
spanglish
to his south florida friends
all right um
hello citizens of miami my name is ken
fresno with revenge of the cis here to
tell you about all the benefits of the
coronavirus vaccine
oh yeah
my bro here dude he's [ __ ] cam fresh
no dude like this who's like from new
york and [ __ ] dude so he's pretty
[ __ ] smart so i want you to listen to
him like you don't talk to you about
health and [ __ ] dude
as you know by now
as a result of operation warp speed
which was uh spearheaded by president
biden
um
we have managed to develop not one but
three separate vaccinations against
covet 19
in addition to booster shots which don't
work
bro like with me at that bite and he's
like he's [ __ ] doing he's like bro
like literally dude take the shot or you
can't [ __ ] go like dude i was a
[ __ ] dolphin mall like this
[ __ ] know what he's talking
about
if you folks do not receive the covet 19
vaccination
uh by february 2nd
uh the dolphins
will never win another super bowl again
hey dude i'm going off scripture because
this guy's kind of a [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] you know marigold a little bit
dude so we're doing this like [ __ ] this
guy we're going to go to kaioto pipple's
[ __ ] play in there dude in front of
la carreta
thank you for your cooperation bro [ __ ]
you dude
[Laughter]
there you go we're now we're getting the
word out there we go okay perfect
um